hey youtubers is Charlie so because
during last week's episode of Game of
Thrones we got a big white Walker
surprise I wanted to do my bonus video
this week about the last great war with
them called the long night and the
building of the wall with bran the
Builder one of the things I really like
about the show is that a lot of the
history is conveyed anecdotally that is
when one character makes a reference to
another character or someone reads
something in a book inside the book so
that's where a lot of our information
about the White Walkers you know even
dragons comes from if you're finding me
for the first time I'm just doing a
series of special bonus videos to
celebrate season four be sure to
subscribe to get everything and feel
free to suggest you know future bonus
topics to me my episode 5 review will
post after that episode airs tonight so
what I'm gonna do is talk about the long
night first and then brand the Builder
building the wall and then three you
know up to where we are right here one
of the really funny things on the show
is that a lot of characters like Jon
Snow know nothing of the long night
remember when old man made that sweet
summer child speech during season one
she was talking to brand because he'd
been born during the long summer the
world of Game of Thrones is a little
weird and that seasons lasts for
indeterminate amounts of time so the
summer as of season one has basically
lasted for about ten years right now
where we are on the show you know right
after the purple wedding is officially
kind of the start of winter or
unofficially they haven't really said
you know winter is here people are very
vague about when seasons come and go but
I think that's one of the reasons why
Dan and Dave chose to include this scene
you know because the White Walkers live
in the lands of always winter so it just
implies that winter is basically here
whether people know it or not the long
night was a little bit different in
terms of seasons in that it was a period
of extreme darkness that lasted for an
entire generation so it was more than
just a long winter and when I say
generation I think we can assume based
on life expectancy that it was about you
know maybe like 50 or 60 years whenever
we first learned about the long winter
during season one man was actually
trying to tell brand a story about
Brandon the Builder the person he's
named after that was his stark ancestor
that built the wall at the end of the
long night that was during the time of
the first men remember during season two
the Nights Watch visited the fist of the
first men when Jon Snow split off with
Ygritte and Sam saw the white Walker for
the first time so we don't know a lot
about what happened you know in the
middle
or the beginning of the long night but
we do know about its end and that
involved a person called the last hero
whenever you look at his triumph over
the White Walkers he sounds a lot like
MELAS Andrews version of azure a high
just someone who saves the world from
darkness there's some books about him at
the Nights Watch that talk about the
obsidian blades being able to hurt White
Walkers but we really only learn about
that as Samwell learns about it so I'm
hoping we get to see him in the library
more and one of the biggest problems
right now is that all the books that
were written were not written during
that original time they were written
thousands of years after those events
happen by maesters and other scholars so
a lot of it could also be false in the
chronology of the show the long night
was actually about 8,000 years ago or
ended about 8,000 years ago the children
of the forest were also a big part of
that time in history technically it's
referred to as the Age of Heroes that
began whenever the first men signed the
pact with the children and a different
war it's believed that when the last
hero ended the long night he did so only
with the help of the children so again
we only learn about these types of
things whenever characters in the show
tell it to other characters you know are
we here a legend I'm hoping that a lot
of George RR Martin's new literature
will actually cover some of these
periods in history so he can fill in the
gaps you know and officially sign stuff
into canon here's where we need to talk
about the wall and bran the Builder
though he was the founder of House Stark
we know he was alive at the end of the
long night but I can't confirm that he
was present at the signing of the pact
between the children of the forest and
the first men there's really no official
timeline for those events yet so the
rumors say that whenever Brandon started
building the wall he did so with the
help of the Giants and probably the
wildlings too after a war like the long
night you can imagine that most people
probably put their differences aside so
anyone who was not a servant of the
great other probably helped build the
wall they're also supposedly magic runes
and wards that protect it but we haven't
really learned anything official about
that
so just to dispel any misconceptions
about what the wall is actually made of
yes it is made of ice but they did use a
lot of the natural mountain ranges to
provide some of the foundation
supposedly those big blocks of ice that
were used for quarried from the lakes in
the haunted forest in the wall just
slowly got bigger over the centuries
meaning that when it was first built
during Brandon's lifetime it was way
smaller I just think that's a much more
plausible explanation you know that the
Nights Watch just slowly built it up
over the centuries for example it took
the Great Wall of China about two
thousand years to finish being built so
obviously they did not have the help of
frost giants so you could probably shave
off a couple hundred years for the wall
on Game of Thrones when it was first
started the Nights Watch you know had an
entire army of men helping out and at
its biggest it was about ten thousand
men strong serving in 19 castles all on
the wall right now they're at a fraction
of that in they're only Manning three
castles it's the shadow tower Castle
black and Eastwatch they're basically
you know three castles that are
equidistant from each other you know
from the westernmost part of the wall to
the easternmost part with Castle black
being smack dab in the middle so more
about magic as it applies to the wall
you know right now on the show in season
2 Mance Rayder talked about something
called the Horn of winter that's
supposedly supposed to bring the wall
down but that's just a legend we don't
know if it's true the horn belonged to
your mum the wildling King that helped
defeat the night's king you know way way
a long time ago originally it was said
that the horn was used to call giants to
him but as the legend goes it's also
supposed to be able to bring the wall
down but really that could just be a
literal interpretation of you know
making the Giants smash it down the
actual physical horn that mance claims
to have found is about eight feet long
and it does have runes of the first men
on it the thing I really liked about the
show and the books are that because most
of the information is passed along in
the form of legend there's really no way
to know what's true and what's been
fabricated we do know that dragons exist
and we know that magic exists we also
saw that the White Walkers have a very
real culture in a home of their own you
know way up in the lands of always
winter you can actually see it here on
the map just to give you an idea of how
far away it is from the rest of Westeros
and the wall as you can see based on the
distance from the wall to Winterfell you
know they're suppose at home isn't that
far away but they are separated by you
have this great mountain range small
comfort so it's basically been implied
that you know since the time of the
night King they've just been slowly
rebuilding their ranks we don't know how
big their army is but in my last video
you know my Knights King qai speculated
that because Craster has sacrificed all
ninety-nine of the sons there's at least
a hundred White Walkers if you include
the night's king they do raise
i'ts to form their infantry but we don't
know if every white Walker possesses the
same magic as the night's king but I
would assume yes mostly because I think
of them like I think of Melisandre and
Thoros being servant to the red God each
of them have the same powers even if
their specialties are a little bit
different you know Melisandre can
conjure visions and fire and birth
shadow babies and Thoros can bring
people back to the life I would assume
that the White Walkers each have their
own specialties - so we're probably not
going to learn about that until George R
Martin writes more books or we get
future seasons of the show
but let me know what are you looking
forward to learning most about the
culture of the White Walkers in their
magic
you know either on the show or in the
books in related news my episode 5 video
will post tonight be sure to subscribe
to get it you know right after episode 5
errors and because round 5 of the
giveaway starts and I'm getting ready to
hit 200,000 subscribers and I'm so happy
and you guys have been so awesome I'm
going to double the giveaway so I'm
giving away two gift certificates but
I'll explain that more whenever I post
that episode 5 video right now you can
click here to get that review video I'll
update the annotation as soon as I post
it and you can click here to get my
night skin Q&A thanks so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight high
fives